and we're live on linkedin as well so
i am stuart creek i'm a marketing
manager here at simply learn
to welcome you to our
digital marketing master class on
creating and managing remarketing
campaigns
get us
about brad in a moment you can see him
here he's with us this morning
and i just want to let you know if
you're watching through webex live
please enter your questions in the q a
panel uh brad will get to the q a toward
the end of the session
uh you can chat to all panelists we'll
get messages um
but we'll be basically
responding mainly at the end of the
webinar
and
we'll also have a couple poll questions
one at the beginning one at the end so
i'm going to ask this
first poll
and this will give us an idea of who's
in our webex audience if you're
watching on live stream
by all means uh you can put answers into
your chat
it's a two-part question we ask how much
experience do you have
in the workplace
and
we do a checking question how you're
doing
um
last couple of years we've had surges
rising and falling lockdowns coming and
going
people's work lives and personal lives
being disrupted so we like to check in
to see how everyone is holding up
finish the poll in about 10 seconds
and
3
2
1.
here is the poll result
so we have a pretty uh
even distribution of uh experience here
today brad we have uh
about a third of folks who are still in
school but we have a quarter who are
more than 10 years experience and
across the board in between
and it's also good to see that um
about 90 of our respondents are doing
well or okay
so
good to see that most people are holding
up
well under
under continuing trying circumstances
even after several years
so with that i'm going to go ahead and
introduce you
um
as the
dp chair here at simply learn of
our
digital marketing
curriculum um
one of our co-directors of the program
and
the co-founder of adalysis
author and speaker
i'll let you speak more about yourself
as i transfer
the sharing privilege to you so you can
start your presentation so perfect so
yeah i'm brad guettis i've been doing
paid search since
last century since 98
and have been through just about
every type of marketing there is
now just to check stuart can you see my
screen and hear me
yes everything is five by five so let's
see perfect and then let me move this
bar over here all right
so what we're doing today is looking at
how to create and manage your marketing
campaigns right we're really speaking to
those who either have never made these
or are more on the beginner side
and so we're going to walk through what
is remarketing how to create your list
some website segmentation
and then creating and managing these
campaigns within google
so first off
get my present working
we've got remarketing and just to just
make sure everyone knows what
remarketing is right what we're
marketing is is you are going to create
audience lists which we're going to
define
which involves putting some code on the
website defining who these groups are
then what happens is someone comes to
your site
if they hit the criteria you define the
audiences then they're put into an
audience group and then they take off
and leave and go elsewhere
right now you
can create remarketing ads and what
you're doing is you're showing across
the google display network could also be
youtube
to those users by audiences so they see
the ads and come back to your site
right then user returns and then another
chance to convert a user
and so when you look overall at you know
paid search
you generally see conversion rates
between two and four percent now some
sites have 20 some have lower but in
general you're talking two to four
and that's on a unique visitor
standpoint
so what happens is a lot of people just
don't convert the first time they're on
your site right and they leave and often
remarketing is in is this reminder to
come back and do something
and so we say you know why should we use
this it was a few stats that really kind
of go to why our market is incredibly
useful
we look at customer journeys these days
consumers visit websites at least six
times on average in the purchase process
so rarely is someone a one-click buy all
right they'll look around a little bit
in retail it's even longer right
consumers consult ten sources of
information and ninety percent switch
devices before making a purchase
and the last that's one of my favorites
right
of people who abandon a shopping cart so
they added something to the cart and
they went to the cart itself and they
didn't actually buy
75 say the intent on returning
now intentions in reality are often very
different i have many lists of things i
intend to do someday
i won't get to a whole lot of them
and so our marketing really does is say
hey you have this experience remember us
or you know maybe you're just a
remodeling company and someone came over
looked at it they're thinking about
remodeling their kitchen
they leave they've looked at some other
places and they finally decided okay we
know what we want to do
where should we do it and that
remarketing as a reminder hey you looked
at us come on back and finish that whole
you know in that case legion process
so when we look across industries
right we see that some industries have
really long purchase cycles if we go to
travel
average person right doing something in
travel
will visit 20 has 21.6 website visits
now it's not 21 different websites they
actually visit nine different sites
about twice each
right in places like apparel about 11
website visits they're going about three
different sites four times each
and so as people are shifting back and
forth you know between where they're
shopping from right your market is that
ad just to say hey come back someone
remembers the brand they often have
better conversion rates your marketing
does than you know a non-branded search
because the user clicking on the ad
knows what they're getting into
now there are two types of remarketing
we have our classic remarketing some
comes to your site they're put in a list
you show it on across gdm
this is common for
non-e-commerce this is going to be where
you're a lot of your legion comes into
play and e-commerce may use a few of the
classic remarketing but not a lot
now when you get into sites that are
powered by feeds so
e-commerce a lot of travel sites
job sites right you have a specific feed
of how things go then you can use
dynamic remarketing
where you're going to create a lot of
the initial things but you're going to
use feed systems like an e-commerce it
would be
adding your merchant center feed
and then the ads are going to show the
actual products the user was looking at
on your website within the ad so that
way if you are ecommerce you don't have
to make a thousand or a hundred thousand
lists of every product scene right for
smaller sites your classic remarketing
which we're gonna mostly walk through
is much better for lead generation sites
that's much better when you dealing with
hundreds or thousands of products
dynamic is usually better
now we talk about remarketing we're
really addressing the bottom of the
funnel right the users already done some
searching looked around a bit right so
our goal here is to bring them back in
that buy section or retention and upsell
or hey you bought a suit do you want a
tie to go with that or you bought this
does this also fit in what you're
looking for
um common in sas products to do upsells
author remarketing
and so we're not talking about new users
right we're talking about a smaller
subset of people who visit our site who
are then trying to turn into customers
so first step is creating audience lists
so you can do this through google
analytics
or google ads tracking and both these
can be implemented through google tag
manager or you can just do it directly
so of course before you can define an
audience you have to track things
properly
so if you're using google analytics then
you're already done right you can just
go and you can jump to the next step
if you're using google ads go into their
section pull the code put it across the
website and actually step one is making
sure you have your tracking codes in
place
step two
is then creating your audiences now i'm
going to use universal analytics here
because it's got some of the best
options
ga4 has these options you have some
different options in google ads
depending on what you're doing
but so we're going to usually start with
an all visitor list hey here's everyone
who visited our website
if you have a a complex analytics setup
you could do all users who were on your
site more than you know 15 seconds
then most people are going to use the
last three options
users who visited a specific section of
the site hey they looked at the shopping
cart they looked at these services
now there are times you do not want to
remarket to someone who has purchased
from you they purchased your legion and
pest control once someone's filled out
your form you don't really want to spend
more money on them
so you can also make an audience list of
people who completed a goal and then
make them a negative audience same with
a positive and say don't show my ads
back to these users
same people who completed a transaction
right if you sell a product that doesn't
really have upsell potential or it's a
one-off type of sale then you may want
to exclude those users
so then you're going to go in and pick
what you want right and then walk those
various conditions that put someone into
that section and we're going to look
through different ways of segmenting
this side of how to make these
you may make many of these where you
might have here's people who visited
one sec somewhere site people who
visited the second section people who
started filling out a form and failed
and didn't finish it
people who finished filling out a form
and then you'll have this whole list of
here's the audiences that we have
created
right and then you can use these to
market back to users
now when you look at ads versus
analytics this is google ad tracking
versus analytics tracking
but the reason
we prefer analytics over google ads is
google ads has real basic options
people who visit a page but didn't see
another type of a page people who used
an app they're real basic
right with google analytics you can use
anything in your analytics data now for
instance
let's say you're using a call tracking
company someone comes to your website if
they call you
right you know this and this data gets
pushed into google analytics
so you could do remarketing the people
who actually called you
i didn't make that sales call hey let's
put them in a list
um you can do a lot more geographic
segmentation
to to reinforce other marketing channels
analytics such as tv commercials or
radio ads based on market size
now if you're using google ads right for
google analytics rather you have to link
the account to google ads you go into
your account you just make sure google
analytics is connected to your google
ads account
and so that gets this gets us you know
our tracking across the website
our remarketing audiences that we can
use and we'll walk through some more
marketing answers in a second with
segmentation
and then you'll have your google ads
audience manager
this is going to show you
all the potential audiences in your
account
now
google is going to look at your
audiences and they're gonna make what
they call similar lists people who are
like those groups
with your marketing we don't want to
deal with those yet right that's other
people who have not had a first party
experience with us
so if you go and say i want to segment
by type app and websites you'll see all
the various lists you've made right how
they're made
is the membership open or closed you can
end a list
and then the various sizes right which
is important so with
um google ads remarketing on display
then you need at least 100 people in
your audience if you want to use it for
search you have thousand people
so that's important to understand the
sizes that you're using now it's still
list gmail campaign um gmail is going to
be
uh sunset is actual campaign type you've
probably seen emails if you're actively
advertising so that will go away soonish
right so we really need to think about
then more than anything else
is determining how we want to create our
list this is where you can use your
brain a little bit here
so let's say we've got an e-commerce
site
and we could look at a site like this
and say they don't do that many things
they they personalize cups they
personalize
um napkins they do some imprint on
plates you know we could just make four
lists and call it good or maybe we make
a fifth list for all visitors and a six
to one for abandoned shopping cart
a seventh for people who bought
now that's our top level segmentation
and that we could just do with our you
know standard remarketing
but if we start drilling down into each
sub category
suddenly our list goes from up seven to
more than three hundred
now this is where you need to think a
little bit
you don't wanna make 300 lists that's
crazy
secondly
does your site get
millions or let's call it tens of
thousands of visitors each month
so you have enough people that you
really want to just use dynamic
remarketing right and that really should
be the way you go with the exception of
maybe abandoned shopping carts in an all
visitor category
if you're really small site that google
doesn't get huge amounts of data you
might want to just
manually manage them um and how the
audiences go
now this is e-commerce and everyone
knows e-commerce sites really go
home page category
um product checkout right that's that's
how they're segmented so it seems fairly
straightforward
not e-commerce is really segmented the
same way
and this is a uh a remodeling company
you go home page and you say interior
exterior when interior right it's
kitchen it's bathroom it's basement
exterior it's painting its fences
so it's still the same process of home
page
category product right lead form instead
of a e-commerce checkout
so every site really is a segmentation
page until someone buys or fills out a
lead form or leaves
and so it's that same process you'd look
at this and say
well interior modeling isn't really what
people look at so we really should do
kitchen and bathroom and basement
individually make a list for each
now that's an ideal world
now as we said we need at least 100
users so if this site is getting at
least
150 people
to each product each month
they should make a list by product
if they're getting a couple hundred
users for the entire website
then they may need to do a little bit
wider segmentation to say well kitchen
we get over a hundred but for everything
exterior we really get a hundred in
aggregate
so we should make one list just every
one exterior and then another one for
kitchen right so as you're thinking
through
how to make your list you're going to
have your analytics open
all right you're going to say
all right here's the list and you can
just jot down you know a list of of our
ideal world of how we want to show back
to users
remember we're going to make an ad group
in the end where we say this audience
this ad this landing page right so just
like search
where someone searches for x we want to
show an ad that says hey we have x and
we can solve your solution go to this
page
the same idea
right someone was on your site left that
are somewhere across google display
network so you want an ad that says hey
we know x and look there's the ad that
says we know x landing page
so you're going to look at analytics and
you're going to be you're saying okay if
i make an audience list with people who
visited this page
do i have at least 100 active users and
that's active and the last 30 days
and right that's active users who have a
cookie enabled
now this is where it gets a little
trickier
as just an overall
rule of thumb if you have a 150 plus
visitors in that audience you're usually
good to go
um one of the problems you run into is
sites with a large number of apple phone
visitors
because apple only allows first party
cookies to exist for seven days then
they kick them out
so you may have problems if you have
exactly 103 visitors and a lot of ios
users
you need to open up your list a bit more
if you don't not a problem but it's
always important just to think through
am i at a hundred
if you want to use the same list for
search am i at a thousand and last 30
days
right so make your ideal list look at
analytics and say can i actually get the
user numbers for this
if yes great i'm good to go
if not i may need to refine or combine
some of these lists together
remembering that as i combine them
together
i still want them to make sense so i can
have a relevant ad to the users in that
audience list
so i think what are the most common
lists right it's all visitors
all converters by type
all shopping cart or form abandoners um
logged in users for sas super super
useful because you make them negatives
or or do custom upsell messages
and then the where the thought comes in
is people who visited specific parts of
your site
so once we have our list made right you
need to create the campaigns
now
we're going to talk about marketing
today and that's really our our focus
but you will see google make things
called similar lists and then you've got
your in-market audiences
it's generally best to keep each
audience type separate by a campaign
from other audience types this lets you
manage budgets you run rates and things
just easier overall to do
and then each audience becomes an ad
group
so let me go to our ad groups you know
we click create ad group
and then you'll see your targeting
method right so you're going to go to
audiences and one of the options is
how have they interacted with your
business or your data in similar
segments
right your data is the important
consideration here
so if you choose that you will see a
list here's all the audiences that
you've created linked into google ads
via google analytics or google ads
directly that you can then add to that
individual ad group
now usually you're going to make an ad
group by
a user type but if you realize hey we're
going to show the same ad to people who
were here not 5 days versus 90
you could put them both in the same ad
group
this is a very important step
google likes to slip this in as already
checked
and it's called optimized targeting
with optimized targeting
google automatically expands your list
to similar types of users
now in remarketing right our goal is to
show our ad to people who have had a
website experience with us before
as soon as optimized targeting is turned
on we're showing our ads to people who
have not had a website experience so
we're combining two groups that don't
actually have similar characteristics
so while optimized targeting can be
useful for in-market audiences or
similar types of lists for remarketing
specifically since our goal is first
party users
we do want to turn this off
now once we've turned it off we have our
audiences we need to make response to
display ads
so responsive display ads are real
similar to responsive search ads where
you give google assets and then they're
going to combine various things together
now there are some optional fields logo
being an optional field
if you don't put data in the optional
fields there will be areas across the
web your ad cannot show without a logo
you can't be a native inventory right so
useful to go ahead and fill out every
optional field
if you have brand requirements you can
do things like customize the colors and
change the call to action and things
like that
then because it's responsive display
review the key ad formats to make sure
that your ad looks okay across
your google properties and mobile versus
desktop websites right just to ensure
you look at your ad you're like boy
that's not a very good ad in that
combination need to change your assets
around
right so once you've done all this now
you have an ad group that's got
audiences and ads in it
so we need to manage these so
we go back to our audience manager right
we'll list out all of our audiences
with any audience if we click into the
audience
we're going to see
what the audience name is and then it's
search size where it's eligibly
displayed
now in addition we're going to see
our demographic data
we're going to see country information
location information
and then we're gonna see devices used
so if you know here's our ideal customer
profile right most people who buy from
us fit this kind of category or people
shopping for
this specific product usually fit this
demographic
and if you look at you know this is our
ideal and this is what we're getting and
they're not the same
right
there's usually one of two things
happening right one
it was a
some audience implementation wasn't
correct you're getting people on your
list that don't really shouldn't fit
there need to go look at your code and
how it's set up
commonly though it's actually number two
which is there's a different demographic
or group buying from you then you
realized right then i see that all the
time where someone will say our ideal
customer is x y and z
and then they realize oh but also abc is
a really good customer and we didn't
realize this group existed
so looking through your demographic and
your segmentation data even locations
and you can drill down into you know
cities and stuff um
we'll show you a lot more information
about how
right the audience makeup is comprised
then you've got a large list where you
can see where's this audience being used
and where is it being excluded just lets
you see hey this is used in 50 campaigns
or this one is used in one aggro this
one we didn't use at all so maybe we
should actually add it somewhere
all right
so then next we need to think about how
we we do our bidding and management and
so forth
so with remarketing right most bid
methods are going to work
so generally you're going to use a
target roast or a target cpa
and then you can set your target cost
per action your target rawas you know
for your clicks
there is an option for display stuff
instead of paying for clicks to pay for
conversions
i rarely rarely ever see this work well
generally there's so few conversions
that someone switching from pay for
conversions to clicks their conversions
may go up 10x it's it's never worked
quite well even though it's been an
option for
seven eight nine years now
so you can use any kind of display
method you want or bid method you want
now with remarketing we need to talk
about attribution as well
so for those of you newer
right
if someone
clicks on a search ad
then they click on they search for a
brand they click on a brand ad
and then they click on remarketing ad
and convert
right so they technically three ad
clicks here
attribution modeling says how do we
divvy up the credit for three
interactions
so by default
right you either have last click or data
driven
right last click says give all the
contribution to the last ad clicked
which makes remarketing look really good
but then the brand click and the other
click got zero
right attribution for it they appear not
to get any conversions
if time decay
the closer to the conversion the higher
value the click is
there's linear
meaning if there's three clicks then
give everything 33 of the credit
position based give first click and last
click more credit and divvy up that the
credit the other clicks in the middle
somewhat and then first click which is
usually a growth oriented strategy of
give everything to where they found us
ignore everything else
now the reason this really matters
if someone
searches for an ad then clicks for
marketing and then searches branding
converts
right if you're using last click
remarketing and your uh generic keyword
never got any credit
so if you're using automated bidding
those bids over time if that scenario
repeated stuff would go to zero
right so google has switched for new
campaigns um to data driven being the
default
if you don't get a lot of conversions
data driven is actually just linear just
just note that right it's an important
note
so with remarketing our goal is to bring
people back who have been here before
right which says hey we should have
there should be two clicks in this
conversion process now click one could
have been organic and click to come from
marketing ad
but a lot of times there'll be multiple
paid ads in the process
so you must use an attribution model
when you're when if you really want to
evaluate remarketing in your entire
account correctly
secondly
go into your conversion data
see if your attribution models are
consistent
this type of setup which i see all the
time where
one's position based another one's last
click another one's linear another one's
data driven another conversion is last
click again right and and this starts to
create all kinds of issues
because based upon the type of
conversion the data gets changed in how
it gets placed back in the account
making some really really messy data
so it's generally best to choose an
attribution model that works for your
company and it's often a cmo you're the
chief marketing officer decision of how
they you almost view attribution
and then making sure that all your
conversions your counting in goals
are using the same model otherwise
things get real messy real quick
with how your data flows and automated
bidding not really being able to work
very well
and so that's that's that step of
getting your data in correctly
now again with remarketing we're often
getting assisted conversions
right which means
someone is clicking on an ad clicking on
marketing buying through another channel
they entered in
and we often want to look at what clicks
are assisting our conversion values
so if you go into your your google ads
account
right go to your conversions your
multi-channel funnels
and then you can see assisted
conversions
and you can drill down into campaigns ad
groups even keywords here or in this
case audience lists
to see how much any group is assisting
in conversions but is not being directly
attributed to conversions
and this is just a nice evaluation to
look at how the audiences are
contributing
across even non-uh paid sources because
this is not your attribution modeling
and your your cisco version that in
google ads
doesn't care about you know was it a
google ads click right was if it came
from facebook and then linkedin and then
organic and remarketing right you want
to see how everything fits in the in the
overall conversion flow and the assisted
data can give you some of that
all right so as you set this up there's
a lot of other things to kind of
consider and this is for more of our our
10 plus year people here today
one is using remarketing to reinforce
touch points
so this is a common conversion flow or
data flow lead flow
in b2b
where you've got you know clicks of the
website
and then your goal number one is to have
them download a white paper
if they downloaded a white paper you
want them to attend a webinar you
collect the email when you
they download the white paper you email
them say hey see a whole webinar how
this works
if someone
went to the webinar and they watched
more than 30 minutes or 70 percent or
whatnot you hand it out to a sales rep
right the sales rep calls them up and
calls them up and finally maybe you get
a sale from that
now in reality you could use then your
your cell data to change how you do your
bidding depending on time lapse
but also right you can use remarketing
to reinforce the next stage of the
funnel
so if someone completed a form you make
remarketing and hey attend a webinar if
they went to a webinar your your next
one remarketing ad is hey talk to a
sales rep now this of course would be
different in sas or other product types
but if you have multiple steps someone
goes through before they buy
but then changing your remarketing ads
to be this is the next step we want you
to do and reinforcing that
is a really nice way of moving people
through especially very long funnels
that could take months of time to get
through that much more commonly be to be
some b to c considerations
other times you want to reinforce
other channels
so we see you know over the past you
know gosh maybe 10 years now it's been
quite a while
um one of the top things that cmos have
wanted to do
is better integration
of messaging across channels and and a
lot of companies you know they've had
this wish for years
and they don't do it well
and and part of the reason is they're
not thinking through
how we all the various options possible
to us
so for instance this is a company we
work with who does a lot of tv
commercials a huge amount
and one of the things they want to do is
when a tv commercial airs
assuming you know non non-time delayed
traffic right real-time traffic
then roughly
70 of visits happen between the
commercial ending and 30 minutes later
right there's usually about a 30-minute
window where someone sees the ad and
they search the brand they go to the url
and they add whatever it is
right so with your flight schedules or
your tv flight schedules you should know
here's the region where it's going to be
displayed here's the time when this
commercial is going to air and so forth
so this remarketing list says
only put people in it if they're in
detroit
and it's between 9 and 9 35 at night
right and so this is the commercials
airs airs daily now you can add other
conditions to it if you're sponsoring tv
games you can make you know different
types of conditions
but now they know that even though we
have our different you know audience
list they've got a lot of them
right if someone's in the tv list then
we're going to make sure the images we
use are what we're currently using our
tv commercials
so that way a user is having a the same
experience right what they view on tv as
what they actually see on the web email
campaigns same thing often you may send
out special offers via email
your general audience might not see
these offers right you might have here
is our loyalty email we send out
right and so if someone came from the
email they looked at the offer on the
website but didn't buy yet
right you can say only put them this
audience list
if they're from email source on our
campaign monthly discounts loyalty users
whatever it is
and then show them that same remarketing
offer across the web based on what they
saw in email and you could redo the same
thing i mean we could talk radio we
could talk hulu it doesn't matter right
overall the goal is to say
here is an imagery and you know some
slogan or offer they're seeing
and they come to our site and they don't
buy from that offer
so how do we reinforce that offer or you
make specific audience lists to go and
show it back to them that's much more
advanced usage
right from overall where you're going to
start
right is think about remarketing let's
just see
show ads to users based on website
behavior it's also called behavioral
marketing by the way so when you hear
people say we're doing behavioral
marketing right remarketing is
behavioral marketing you're saying this
is the behavior on the website they went
to this page this page left right that's
an audience segment
so then where you're going to spend
a lot of your initial creative time
is thinking about your website
segmentation
how do you make lists
what user
behaviors do you want to show and add to
if someone did x y or z
do you want to show that to them
what ad should they see based upon their
behavior
so if you think we want to show as we
hooded a
and we want to show ads people who did b
but and the ad can be the same
you could technically use the same list
we want to show out someone who did a we
want to show ads to someone who did b
and they should be different ads for
different types of offers or products
two different lists
right so it's a big part it's just
saying how do we want to make our lists
because this is going to define
everything about your ad group setup and
how how successful you are
so just remember display remarketing
must have a hundred active cookies in
the past 30 days you can use them on
search it's a thousand cookies
right so this is the initial setup and
spend some thought time here
right what behavior do we want to
reinforce and then spend marketing money
right to show an ad for
secondly then we need creation so we're
going to create a campaign just for
marketing
we're going to create an audience
usually per audience list there may be
exceptions where there's a few audiences
in the same ad group though
we want to make sure the ads reflect the
audience's creation and purpose
why do you make this list
so even as having a simple spreadsheet
that's
here's the list name here's how they
something gets added to the list
here's the purpose that we created this
for here's the type of ads you want to
show you know here's the date it was
added or whatnot right let you just
quickly remind yourself especially if
you create it now or you create it 10
years ago and you're like why do we make
this list what's it for and having that
key of just you know
organized notes
right now you have your management
so you want to make sure your audience
characteristics fail your ideal customer
or
you're reevaluating customer profiles
really really useful it's either a yep
this is exactly who we thought was
buying or
this group is spending a lot of our
money
a do we want to exclude the group
because they're not you know actually
buying even though they're getting in
our marketing list or b we need to
reevaluate the demographics of our list
i mean you can just pretty much any bid
method
and then make sure you're using an
attribution model
that's going to not be just last click
or first click that's going to
distribute credit
among multiple clicks to properly use
remarketing
all right and with that stuart i'm going
to hand it back to you to talk about
certifications before we get to uh
hopefully some really good q a
yeah as a matter of fact
let me get back here
and
i'll get back to my presentation
that's the closing slides here
all right so
um
i'm going to ask
a poll question before we get to the q a
we'll do this really quick
we do have several questions from the
audience and and if you have other
questions for brad it's time to put them
into the q a box but let me
open this poll for
our webex audience here
and we're curious to know we've talked
about
the website conversion process today the
remarketing the drive conversions
um what are the things that
you want to add to your marketing
toolkit personally
and what are the skills that you're most
interested in learning
and
uh as a
corollary to that is when would you like
to get started
into doing that
and we'll close the poll in about five
seconds here
right
show this
so it's a pretty much
all the skills across the board
with
seo website conversion content marketing
social media analytics
a little less interest in email mobile
uh mobile i'm sorry um but it's
encouraging to see that nearly half the
audience is interested in getting
started
learning this right away so
and as brad mentioned there's a couple
of certifications that you could pursue
um
we have here at simply learn a number of
different project
programs i'm sorry
um
we have a couple called the digital
marketing specialist and digital
marketing associate
these uh are both
fairly comprehensive the digital
marketing specialist covers
um
a good deal more material it's a
12-month program
but it goes into
almost all of the the
skills that were on that list digital
marketing associate a little bit
less in-depth but still covers
a very broad spectrum of those skills
and these are both completely online
they're programs that you take
you know from your desktop they include
live virtual classrooms they're not
uh just
you know watching videos and
taking quizzes they're
actual projects and
hands-on learning that you do
we also have a version of our program
through
a partnership with purdue university
which is
internationally recognized
u.s university
and we developed this curriculum in
association with meta and their their
blueprint advertising program
with content from harvard business
publishing
it is
and the
i should have updated this slide here
because the next cohort actually starts
in
july but i will
provide that for you but it's a
six month program it is five to ten
hours a week it's very comprehensive
again live virtual classrooms
covers you know
14 different projects a capstone project
that ties everything you've learned
together
includes membership in the purdue alumni
association
you get a certificate from purdue
university
with other certificates you can earn
from
meta
and
includes ama sessions with the folks
from meta facebook
so this is a
great program that covers
the basics of digital marketing
pay-per-click web analytics
social media brand management and then
as i mentioned you tie all that together
into your capstone project where we pose
a problem to you that a real company
would face in the real world and you
develop the solution which you can then
show off
as part of your portfolio so
as we
go through the process each step builds
to the next
until you get your certificate and you
do have the ability to take
additional topics as electives
so i'm not going to go to the thank you
slide yet because right now we want to
get to
q a and
let me
stop sharing the screen so you don't
have to share it stare at the slide
while we're talking about the questions
and answers that have come in
so
right now we have
start with
a question from reem
brad he asked as you were talking about
um
cookie tracking and
building your audience list from people
who have you know 100 people that have
cookies
how do you know if the users decided not
to use cookies is there any way that you
can tell
uh if the cookie is going to expire or
if uh
some other barrier there i mean in
theory yes right because you you know
you have the pop-up that says you want
to be tracked or not um those consider
poll results where you save that to your
database with the pages look at you know
where paid people went um it's
not worth the effort quite honestly it's
way more work than you're really gonna
get out of it
and that's why instead of saying hey we
need a hundred users we often just say
well if our io ios usage is under you
know 25 percent then
if we get to 150 we're good to go and
and that's really where it comes down to
because yet in theory yes you could it's
a really complicated solution that
i don't think i've ever seen someone
build um because it's just
what you get isn't worth the effort
yeah and you're essentially trying to re
reverse engineer around
the user's attempt um to avoid privacy
intrusions
they're if they're not using cookies or
if they're canceling you know
cookies it's because they don't want you
to have that information so
um kind of an
odd catch-22 situation
something that
that if you try to do it it may be worth
more trouble than it's worth as you said
yeah um
do i do by the way want to encourage
people in the
uh live audiences on youtube and
linkedin you can put questions for brad
into the chat
and they'll get relayed to us um
quinoa asks
how do you start
an affiliate marketing program how do
you get started with affiliate marketing
oh gosh i mean all right okay so you're
going to clarify that do you want to be
an affiliate or you company starting an
affiliate marketing program they're very
different directions
and they have
yeah so if you if you clarify that then
i can talk a little bit about
that next step
okay um
yeah actually i'm gonna if chinwe wants
to put
a follow-up into the chat
uh to clarify but let's start with the
assumption that
um
he
wants
well let's see
no i'm not going to start with that
assumption because i'm not sure which
one he wants to do so
i'll wait until he responds um
row heat asks what i think is
regarded as kind of a loaded question
which is what is the most effective way
of digital marketing according to
uh research and so
um
it's it's not loaded right it's sir well
a so when you say the word effective is
undefined
right is effective brand recognition
right then you're going to get into
often in a digital marketing standpoint
um video ads and potentially social you
know viral social ads
if by effective you mean
cost per sale
then it's straight up search okay with
search someone says i want this
you have a keyword that says i in an ad
that says i have this perfect match and
you're you're filling demand
so
the word effective is really the the
iffy definition of what are you trying
to accomplish but um it's hard to beat
search in any marketing channel ever
because you're answering essentially
direct questions that people have
uh varan uh asks are you required to add
a remarketing tag as an extra or can you
use your
google analytics text
you can you can use your google
analytics tag you don't have if you've
got google analytics you can configure
it all from there with no additional
coding on the website
okay
and
here's an interesting question from from
cart
do you think
the verbatim seo or sem what do you
think
bo in the reality the the word is both
um any company should be doing both
whether
if you pick you as a career this is more
what you like more right it's more do
you like the ad persuasion and micro
targeting where seo is a much broader
website thing
from a company standpoint they're not
mutually exclusive they both should be
used as marketing strategies
okay um
unidar asks do you need to implement a
logon on your website in order to
capture
information about visitors or are there
other ways to do that without
that step
yeah you don't need to log on i mean a
form fill you can capture visitors even
google analytics across your website
you'll get information on
every page they visited you have
personal information
but logins are
often
lower
conversion rates because if you make
someone log on before they can check out
right often that's like another step and
you're going to see a higher abandonment
so no no logon is is necessary to track
and use any of the stuff we talked about
today
okay i got a message from chinwe who
who's just basically re
reasserts you'd like to start affiliate
marketing so can you give a
brief view from each of the two
directions
i'm like sure so if you're if you're a
company starting an affiliate marketing
program
right essentially affiliate marketing is
when you as a company
are
letting other people promote your goods
or services
and then if they sell something you know
they usually send them to your website
if something is sold you give a
percentage back to the person or a
dollar amount or what not
um so if you are a company starting an
affiliate program it all starts with the
research of the software you're going to
use to track all of this
right every affiliate marketing software
is different in how it is payouts how it
how it tracks cookies
options
if someone um
you know is sending
um
more leads than anyone else do you get a
special bonus
um some softwares will automatically
discount paid search or keywords because
many companies will
bar their affiliates from using brand
terms because they don't want affiliates
to steal brand traffic just to sell it
back to them
so the software is the most important
step that companies go through in
evaluating
picking an affiliate marketing program
right they're gonna institute this the
the software which is gonna require dev
and integrate it into either shopping
carts or other systems whatever that
looks like
then they're going to promote the
program
which could be across things like
commission junction and whatnot or on
their site
where they usually not always usually
give away um images and marketing
materials to the affiliates to use on
their behalf
right as an affiliate then you're
essentially marketing for that company
right so you're gonna pick the company
very specifically
based on
how they do cookies like so for instance
amazon does a 24 hour payout
um meaning that if i go if i click your
affiliate link today i go to amazon i
don't buy for three days
you unless you're super affiliate do not
get credit from amazon
but other sites give 30 day cookie
credit right so you're going to evaluate
how long do those cookies live for
am i allowed to use paid search some
companies ebay doesn't allow paid search
affiliates anymore they suffered several
years ago
how are you going to market it what's
your unique take on the affiliate market
and then lastly from a long-term
consideration
if you don't exist does anyone care
right it's an important question to ask
so for instance
if you look at a site like um
expedia
expedia is an affiliate right they're a
gigantic affiliate
but expedia sells nothing they sell
hotels and and airline tickets on behalf
of other companies
so if exp disappeared a lot of people
would care a lot affiliates are more
like here's a quick comparison
pick one i'm out of the picture
right and there's no long-term branding
being built up it's a
i must keep doing traffic today
or i no longer get paid and so often
you're going to think of an affiliate
long term as a business model um it may
take you a couple years to really think
through the business model part of it
right that that's something you have to
to get started but choosing who you want
to be affiliate for is really important
from cookie duration and payouts to make
sure that you are uh you're getting paid
properly for the traffic you're sending
great
um i have a question from srihamadja
which is
how do we get to know how many people
have visited our website
basically
analytics right so if you don't know
everyone on your website you need to
install analytics
um google analytics is the is the one
most people start with because it's free
and then you can go into your analytics
data once it's installed and see people
on site how many what pages they went to
how often they went to it et cetera but
start with if you don't have that data
start with google analytics
uh amit asks
how does twilio segment
compared against the google analytics
context
more and more limitation of third-party
cookies
if the limitations on cookies are
affecting digital marketing
does that affect
julio users
more than
google analytics
i don't know twilio well enough to
answer that question of what they do or
how that's different
um
you know in many cases the
the cookie ban is really more about
third-party cookies than first party
cookies right if you get rid of
first-party cookies no one can log in on
your website you will no longer have an
amazon account right you will no longer
have a google ads account or a gmail
account so
it's the third party cookies which are
often
really getting removed right first party
is a very very important integral part
of the web and google analytics puts a
cookie down as if the website the person
is on
right set the cookie so google analytics
is a first party cookie which is
important to note
but cookies aren't going away there's
being limited in some capacities but
and so he asked question what
would the tempo or frequency of a
remarketing campaign
what should that be that's a great
question right so
frequency is how often someone can see
your ad in a time frame
um
and
search markers have a tendency to under
do frequency capping right so number one
if you're using automated bidding
google will take frequency caps into it
they will determine frequency caps as
part of the automated bidding so often
you actually don't want to use it
then next step is
how
how long does someone take to make a
decision
right so if someone is doing something
that's a very fast immediate need
right you may not want a frequency cap
because you want to almost bombard them
with ads until they're like you know i
give right and i know that's not the way
we really want to phrase it but in
reality right if it's something you're
gonna you're gonna pick in 24 hours
don't limit your frequency
um now let's say you're doing a college
or university right remarketing campaign
often this could be anywhere from a a
week to a six-month decision on where to
go to school
so you don't want to and they're not
cheap clicks you don't want to pay for
someone clicking here ad 100 times over
six months
so in that case you're often going to
use now frequency cap that's maybe like
seven to ten at most per week
um and
by the way an impression on google is
50 of the ad was seen for more than one
second
right that's what that's an impression
is on google um
and so it's in if you're a b2b company
that wants to do a slow reminder about
you know we're salesforce and we offer
these three
you know things you can also integrate
in your system but you may never do it
they might do something like hey three
to five a week
right at most and then just run it for a
year and that way maybe eventually like
okay i want to take a look at this now
so there's no magic answer um most
defaults is seven to ten times per week
with with some exceptions okay very
good um
that's pretty much all the questions we
have
right oh we have one that just came in
from mayak
um
could you please advise changes in data
input for your marketing strategies
considering changes from ua to ga4 you
know what gm i'm gonna cop out on this
answer ga4 is still so buggy and has
problems that we've had issues with
people trying to move to ga4 and getting
audiences always to work consistently
because ga4 is an event-based system
um ga4 is not going away and our our ua
is not going away until 2023 you've got
about a year left
um
so
most
companies are using their ua remarketing
and they will probably until next
january february
when they got about six months to then
you know switch it all over to ua so i
have not looked at all the event stuff
and audience stuff enough in in uh the
new ga4 to give good advice yet but i
just know that our clients are not going
to move audiences
until next january february is when they
put their dev time for it
um i think that's all the questions we
have
i'm car i'm going to tell you that
brad did address your question about seo
versus scm so when you look at the uh
replay of this uh we'll be sending a
link for
replaying this uh webinar for reference
um you can check his answer which had to
do with what you're most interested in
tomcar got two different job offers one
for seo one for sem
sem i so i personally love scm way more
than seo you know about
when panda pan panda penguin and pigeon
all came out back to back to back about
i don't know seven eight years ago now i
you had to pick one i couldn't i
couldn't do both
and i personally the micro targeting and
the ad strategy and integrations of paid
search i way prefer over seo
you might like site speed and digging
into code
right so it's really more where do you
what do you what's your love right what
do you really enjoy is it
defining creative ways to target people
is it a lot of content and server stuff
they're very different jobs yeah
okay so i'm going to drop into the chat
right now a link to
the
home page for our
purdue digital marketing pgp as well uh
you can download the program brochure
and find more information
um
and
the next cohort actually starts in
mid-july so
that's in there and with that i'm going
to also
thank brad
um we're going to
go back to these
final slides here
and
i'm going to put into the chat
um the
linkedin link that you see in front of
you so that you can contact him
hold on a moment while i
wrangle the
selection option here
and
linkedin e-whisper on linkedin
is
handle there
but thank you so much bradford for this
session
you really went into a great deal of
depth and
information about
the the strategies for remarketing and
really great information
thank you for hosting us once again
okay i
uh you are so more than welcome
and um
i'll also let everybody know that into
the chat i am dropping this information
about how to get to this particular
career master class next wednesday if
you'd like to join us for this webinar
um
dr chala
will talk about how to craft your
personal story
um
personal branding in your personal story
and what you tell people about
who you are what you do what your
professional
experience expertise goals are
is a really important part of career
management so this is a great session we
invite everybody to join us next
wednesday
and with that i just want to invite
everyone to keep track of us on our
social media channels
at simplylearn at facebook and twitter
simply learn on linkedin
thanks again to brad and thank you to
everyone in our
webex youtube and linkedin live
audiences for joining us today we hope
this was valuable to you
and we
would love to welcome you into the
simply learn
learning community
so for brad and simply learn i'm stuart
creek and thank you very much
thanks
you